uh so remember
we talked about this hold on you don't
even know what it is yeah you're
laughing and nothing's come up
[Music]
who's what's up with the mcpoyle
brothers over here
so remember travel bum he's the one that
did the asylum pick up the that was
totally wasn't staged with that
chick in barcelona but that chick who
totally was not an expensive prostitute
correct
so this is so remember he does these
classes how much you looked it up i was
like what was it five g's or something
like that six
six six don't discount this man's skills
you're right so uh this is him
this is one of his students that he's
working with
let's check it out maybe not but what's
in control is
your permission to say i want to see you
again put your phone under here
yeah don't ask me no wait he's the
pickup artist
in this one yeah dude he's a stud look
at him
you haven't looked at their website have
you he's like the second
guy in charge there's something
hilarious though about a guy who looks
like this and he's super confident
yeah hello ladies
the unity of dating and spiritual
awakening
[Music]
what if you could see the world the way
i see the world where no one is a
stranger
i hate this guy i hate him
[Music]
we go to places where the exchange rates
are really good and we buy women
no english
i just saw you
i wanted to say hi have a lovely day
he's got a microphone on him this is
creepy right
it's very creepy
everything great sat down started
talking she was open
to have you lost her sharing about
yourself you said what you loved
you said i love coffee right then you
quickly made it about
having coffee with her why do you think
that didn't work out in that moment
because all of this is a scam and it's a
ponzi scheme and you're selling false
hope to people who
really on the inside what they need is
somebody to love them and care about
them
and instead you want to turn them into a
[ __ ] carnival trick i don't know
though
that's just me [ __ ] spitballing yeah
you're you're you're you're selling
poison to people
because what is this you're
conceptualizing and i always
point out with these guys like you're
taking what should be just genuine
moments of meeting people and
like look i'm not against people that go
out and you know pick up chicks and want
to [ __ ] and like all that kind of hey
you know do you but like when you start
treating it like
everything is a system and a transaction
and everything is a you know what i mean
like everything's
you start dehumanizing people to the
point where
it's it really is only a small leap from
there where you're like
killing hookers and like peeling their
skin off and making a girl suit like
once you can get to a level where you're
not even looking at the people you're
talking to as humans
and you're like you know what i liked
about it bro was that like she said
and then you worked an angle in
right and then you used the the theta
method
which then she like it's like i know
you're riffing but i'm angry at even
that because it makes me angry
because it's all like why don't you just
go talk to somebody
and like maybe several times a day you'd
be like hey what's going on and they're
like not interested and you're like
okay jesus you know and you just learn
how to be okay
like most of the guys that pay for these
programs i could save you a lot of money
right now
just get very comfortable with with the
little paying of pain that you feel when
girls go i'm not interested go away
weirdo yeah like just get okay with that
and if you can get okay with that you're
not gonna do this
could should i can i talk to her i don't
you could just go up and talk to people
once you really don't care
that the only thing that they can say to
you is no i have a boyfriend go away
yeah you're like
all right whatever it was worth a shot
right like these guys are making you
think that there's the perfect sequence
of things you can do and get any woman
and it's just not how it works
it really is just a numbers game it's
just like selling a car
you want to sell a lot of cars talk to
as many customers as possible
you're still not you're going to convert
the same percentage
but instead of talking to one person you
talk to 10 people
you sold two cars like it these people
look at it like where it's like you got
to use a method in
this system and chart it and then write
down your progress and then
make sure the next time you watch this
video it's just go up and talk to people
and most girls are gonna go
go away [ __ ] and then every once in a
while somebody's gonna go
yeah that seat's not taken and you're
like oh
what up it's like snipe's pretty easy
dude
and like roy said what you're doing to
these [ __ ] these already borderline
elliot roger
weirdos is you're gonna make them drop
six grand
they're gonna feel like they're doing
the system right
why the [ __ ] isn't the system working it
must be these goddamn [ __ ]
and then it's like really oh it's very
very slight jump into
now i'm gonna start killing these [ __ ]
sort of realm
mentally and it's like gonna be on you
guys and they're gonna be even angrier
when they're killing these [ __ ]
because they're gonna be like i dropped
six grand on this like i could have went
to a trade school for that
wouldn't you be mad if this guy showed
up as your coach for six grand
like this guy doesn't look like someone
who's picking up chicks on this
on the easy i mean maybe to them and
maybe
that's a selling point if you think
about it to to at least the marks in the
situation
where it's like oh if this [ __ ]
[ __ ] average or ugly looking dude can
do it i can do it
you know yeah and also they're doing it
in these second and third world
countries where americans and westerners
are
looked at as like you know oh [ __ ] you
can have money
you'll probably have you know what i
mean like you're talking about the
you're talking about ukraine where these
people are you can live
comfortably for a thousand dollars a
month so if you're making youtube big
bucks like you can go over there
anybody's gonna think you're cool if
you're staying at a luxury hotel and you
have money
and that's these guys do these no not
you notice none of these pickup artists
they're all from either
england or they're from america none of
these guys
operate any of this [ __ ] in england or
america you notice that
can i get you guys they pay to send me
on one of these retreats they
all got to take the gimmick to the
philippines
or thailand or
you know romania or like you know what i
mean it's a macedonia
they go to these places that are very
carefully chosen
because everybody there is poor and the
women are gorgeous
and they're very plentiful so it's like
there's a bunch of bored
like young melania trump looking [ __ ]
walking around that probably their dad's
a farmer
and then you're like hey what's up you
want to go stay at this luxury hotel i
got cocaine and they're like
yeah and then you go see so the method i
used
it's like stop it not as a universal
thing oh
this doesn't work in this moment all the
time why in this moment
she said no thank you and it propelled
you even into the momentum of saying
okay
nice to meet you goodbye what do you
think happened there
i felt i i needed to come to the
conclusion
or the the question right um
because of the no english thing she
didn't
she didn't speak english so i was like
well then i'll
go for the punchline
by the way shakes in the chat merch
hates that he isn't the one doing this
you think i can't afford to fly to
ukraine and buy a bag of coke
of course and get a hotel that in new
york city would cost
thirteen hundred dollars a night but
over there it'd probably be like 200 a
night
it's very doable for anybody that wants
to do that
like that's not that's not a thing where
you're like you're just jealous that
he's doing this
it's not difficult like anybody can go
to the philippines
with 500 on them you know what i mean
and go live like an afghani opium
warlord it's not
if somebody's not doing that it's
because they don't want to
we escalate to the end yeah um
beautiful square though so let's try to
like capitalize in the moment
capitalize because all the other things
i will say
will not be understood it's travel bomb
underscore coaching for those of you
that have six thousand dollars laying
around
so let's just go for that the
presumption
that a lot of things you might say or do
might not be understood or received
because
just her first pushback of saying i
don't speak english is the
default defensive thing to a foreigner
or
hear me out here maybe
she doesn't speak english because you
are not
in their country they could possibly not
but but this whole key pushing thing is
is so
rapey yeah it's kind of rapey right
yeah and and her being sensitive to her
capacity to not be able to
sustain a conversation in english and so
she'll say that
but she doesn't know how you'll make her
feel in your ability to maybe
not speak english and speak silence
emotion small simple english maybe you
know she doesn't know how that's gonna
make her feel
so you have to gauge that in the moment
you know and feel it out and say oh you
know
i can just keep going i can be
continuous not be reactive
and feel that i must do something fast
now because
she doesn't speak english yeah just
ewing it's like it's you you know when
the women
it's it's not as big now but remember
like for a few years ago
when all the women were into that that
book the secret that oprah talked about
where like
you just put your vibes out into the
universe man every day and they'll come
true
this is the dude equivalent of it this
is what it is you you
and then it turns out that you can't
just wish your way into a lab technician
job you know you could actually go to
school for it yeah you have to actually
work towards the goal oh i thought if i
just put
lab tech on my dream board that it was
gonna just come true and it's like well
no
step two is go apply for classes
it sounds like he's trying to [ __ ] these
guys are trying to [ __ ] sell you a uh
a time share like that's what they
should this is this is this time sure
selling technique
but the the best thing that anybody can
understand right is that if
if you're if you're hung up on
this thing where you're like i'm not
getting laid i it's it's
impossible you're doing the same and it
doesn't even apply to getting laid it
could apply to a sales job it could
apply to
anything that you have to apply yourself
to um
you know if if you can look around and
there's a bunch of other dudes that are
average just like you
that are managing to close sales every
day or managing to find women that go
home with them
like it's it's not
there's not a system that they're using
and it's you're the problem
if you're in a room with 10 guys nine of
them
um you know have had a girlfriend in the
last year or whatever and you haven't
had a girlfriend your whole life
it's you you're doing something wrong
and very likely more often than not
it's either because you see guys they
they
like they're fat and they have goofy
glasses and they dress goofy and
like there's guys that are just clueless
and you can tell like they're bad skin
they don't do anything to look nice they
have no sense of style like
should you go talk to one of the more
normal ones and be like you know who
does
who cuts your hair like what kind of
cologne is that like learn how to just
look kind of normal just kind of normal
and then
talk to as many people as possible
that's what's good it's the same way as
looking for a job
like i've i've seen people that are
playing like you ever see those people
that are like i can't find a job to save
my life like
i've posted on facebook like at least
four times
hey guys can anybody find me a job and i
can't find and you're like wait so you
haven't
gone out and looked for a job like you
haven't put a nice shirt and pants on
and gone out and said
hey who's the manager around here i just
want to press the flesh real quick hey
i'm mike man i was just around looking
for a job figured i'd hand you the thing
personally
and you go do that a hundred times and
finally somebody's gonna go
who is the guy that came in the other
day shook my get him the [ __ ] in here
we need somebody it's it's you know what
you said it's a good point it should it
shouldn't just be
we'll go talk to women and do this if
you want to if you want to
have a better chance at this talk to
guys talk to girls and not just by and
i'm not talking about because you're
trying to [ __ ] them
have conversations with people learn how
to
speak you there's this this isn't be a
little [ __ ]
there's nothing to be a street magic
trick to make this happen just be a
person that you could speak to anybody
you could go to a party and you could
talk to anybody
about anything and you'll be fine it
because
if you look at a lot of these dudes you
know the ones that have that have
problems with like
i don't know how to pick up a chick i
don't know how to get laid or whatever
their biggest issue
isn't just that they have a problem
talking with women they have a social
problem with everybody
which outside of romantically yeah they
have an issue the guy that goes to a
party there's 30 people there and you're
talking to nobody right not even the
guys and it's like
you're sitting there with your drink in
the corner like like that meme
[ __ ] losers like the meme with the
guy in the corner and everybody's
dancing
yeah yeah that's that's that's what you
know it's it's just
talk to people it's like anything man
practice makes perfect right
and it's not just if you can't have a
normal conversation with somebody at a
party
without trying to [ __ ] them you're
definitely not going to be able to talk
to a girl and get them to [ __ ] you
like you you can't you can't do that
it's
it's like like royce and i
both like had probably
more often than not like i know royce
has seen me when i was in miami like i
i've been with some women and dated some
women that i had no business
dating and it's again
you can kind of skip a lot of the
homework and you can skip a lot of the
book work
if you can just work a room like you can
skip
a lot of gym you can skip a lot of trips
to the gym
you don't have to be super rich if you
can just be socially it
like you know what i mean that's one of
the things i was always pretty okay
at was just put me in a room with people
i i don't get that like where i go i
gotta
i'm just gonna i'm gonna sit here and
i'm gonna mope like i've always gone
into a room
and i'm the guy that's always like what
do you do for a living like blah blah
blah
you know when you break balls and like
i'll break a stranger's balls before i
even know them
and you take a chance when you do that
but if you're not
meeting people and you're having some
fun and then everybody has a good time
and then yeah sometimes somebody's like
hey this guy's
not great but or funny at least or
become or like you've said before become
a drug dealer
dude honestly uh when in doubt it's
getting late when in doubt break out the
powder baby
yeah i'm i'm learning a lot
at the seminar that i flew out here for
and paid two g's to you guys for
i really appreciate 2 000 is a deposit
it's 3 000 to finish the course
it's still a thousand less than this guy
oh but yeah if you got if you got blow
it's the easiest because
sometimes the difficult move is you're
at a party and it's getting the girl
away from people to like have a little
undivided attention and like not to [ __ ]
them yet or anything but just to talk to
them like you got to get a little bit of
you time in
and that's the best way to do it is
you'd be like you wanna
real quick and then you go in there and
then you got like five minutes of coke
chatter
alone and yeah you build a thing and
yeah they'll [ __ ] you she's not gonna
say no
because of the implication well no in
this case she's not going to say no
because of the cocaine well no it's the
implication that if you don't [ __ ] me
you're not going to get more cocaine
that's true and if you do [ __ ] me you'll
be plenty more there'll be plenty more
cocaine plenty more where that came from
darling
very simple that's how it works they
call me the snowman baby
let's see what happens let's see him on
the streets again speak english
look at the way my god are you walking
with a few seconds
just the women walking around in ukraine
is
just it's it's obscene how good looking
they are
metro i walk with you one minute
i have never taken the metro before i
will not do that now
don't worry but it's cheating
fun job no
what a lot of one-word answers and
they're bothering them
yeah you're bothering people all the way
to work yeah you know
there's another reason i keep bringing
up that they do this in foreign
countries right
because they're a little more polite in
these foreign countries or whatever and
you know you you could never do this in
new york city
no of course not could you imagine
stopping a beautiful woman in new york
city
and going like hey what's up what's your
name you're taking the same subway
oh i'll ride with you yeah so what's up
you like your job what do you do and
like you would you would end up having a
beautiful woman in a three thousand
dollar dress go
get the [ __ ] away from me get the [ __ ]
away like
very loudly in front of people you're
like whoa whoa get
the [ __ ] away from me like okay
jesus but in ukraine they're like yes no
no yes and they're like they're just
afraid he's one of those guys that like
is one of the lower level guys that
works for those dudes and taken
yeah they're gonna be they're gonna be
sold behind some bulletproof grass to a
bunch of [ __ ] cheeks
they're being polite because they don't
end up at a container ship
jumps no fun
it's just what would you do if you
didn't have this job you had all the
money in the world
you don't know listen she's he's she's
giving him a lot of i don't knows no
no no at read the [ __ ] room pal
read the room i would probably
live on an island
[Music]
she didn't ask you what you would do
with myself and
chocolate because i love chocolate you
go in
you're already here
okay
i think you're lovely oh my god do you
like coffee
[Music]
who doesn't like coffee sure
or a phone number
yeah yes i would like you to leave
is awkward in here now oh my god these
and by the way this is another thing
that doesn't work with this pickup
artist [ __ ]
very rarely and it happens but
very rarely can you just go up to a
woman
who is either in the middle of trying to
go from a to b like anybody who's trying
to get somewhere
or somebody who's sitting by themselves
like at a coffee shop like i don't know
why these pickup artists always do that
they go
we got one we got alive when i'm gonna
move in and it's like
nobody wants to be bothered in public by
a stranger
no of course not ever it's not a thing
that women men
nobody wants that i don't i don't want
to be bothered in public by a friend
like that's what i mean if i'm just
sitting at a starbucks and i'm having a
coffee and somebody goes hey
how you doing man you have the time yeah
yeah
yeah i got a job interview here in a few
minutes getting pretty pumped for a cup
of coffee or so like you just start
chatting you'd go like after a while
you'd go can you leave me alone i'm not
trying to be a dick but if i wanted to
be here talking to somebody
i would have called one of my various
friends to meet me here
so i could talk to somebody while i had
my coffee i'm here alone
because i just need this moment right
now and you're ruining it for me you
know who was great at that
stopping that our buddy dutch he gets
when he gets on airplanes
he wants to be left though like most
people don't be left alone and he says
every time a chatty person is sitting
next to him
like he'll have his headphones in you
know like normal and when they stop
talking he goes
slowly wraps his headphones around his
phone and then he goes
yes and they'll be like oh i just wanted
to know blah blah blah he'll be like
blah blah blah that's actually then he
slowly unwraps it actually
puts him back in [ __ ] by the way and
they don't bother him the rest of the
flight
dutch is the biggest [ __ ] i've ever met
of course but
like and i mean it in in the most
complimentary way possible i like i've
been out with dutch before i've had some
wild nights out with dutch
and yeah he really is a [ __ ] but like
he's one of those guys like when he does
[ __ ] to me i get really annoyed
but man when i watch dutch do it to
other people i'm always like this is the
most amazing thing ever
that really is great though yes so you
say look you're putting them in whatever
you're setting up and the guy's like
yeah you saw
my first time going i'm headed to bubba
but so he really does do
he does this you have to say you go
wrap it around like 20 seconds to do it
and be like
yes yeah you're right that really makes
you just feel like
you know what he doesn't embarrass me at
restaurants when the waiters waitress or
waiters taking too long
he really puts his hand up and pulls the
other hand to hold it up and he does
this
and he he he will hold it up there for
an
awkward amount of time and i'm like
dutch touch just wait she's gonna come
by [ __ ] stuff what are you doing
dutch is a [ __ ] but i love him i love
him
i've witnessed him not do [ __ ] like that
i've never been on a plane but i've
witnessed him do dutch-like things and
i'm just like
that was great does he take puppets on
the public with him no that's i do that
that's more fun it felt like
loosened up a little bit through the
conversation
as in also the dude on the right
doesn't look like he would have a
problem he has a normal looking guy he
looks like he'd have a problem getting a
chick right like
he's not like the guy on the left the
one walking around with his shirt open
like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] the one on the left the
one teaching him should have the issues
the one on the right looks like a normal
guy that should easily be able to pick
up chicks by the way the guy on the left
maybe shouldn't have his shirt open when
he has a [ __ ]
jake the snake robert's body right
yes well he is doing ddp yoga now she's
got like that
hairy out of that that's that would be
like me just walking around with an open
shirt like a sport jacket put no t-shirt
underneath
hello ladies i feel like what are you
doing are you trying to do a bad loose
leisure suit larry thing like what are
you doing
sorry i just wanted to pop my chest out
get my nips a little bit of air
before i was still a bit like
there was a pause just before we went in
the metro
right actively noticed like okay
boss
and then i saw a little with her like a
little
it's quiet like so i am very curious
when do we
um when do we begin the raping because
you have to promise me
for six grand a month i could come here
and you would uh we would
be commencing the raping
the guy's like dude [ __ ] chill man
not on camera oh
tell you about the raping later [ __ ]
mike dude it's a hot mic
you told me we would be kidnapping women
and raping them here in the ukraine
stop you made me pay you 500 for drugs
to put them to sleep dude it's a live
stream
stop i can't even take this back so
we're not doing the raping
then i continued these guys look like
they're in love
they do the guy in the left looks like
the end of a movie where some with
someone has aids and he's just saying
goodbye to his lover
you're right but the other one didn't
get it yeah they didn't get it
and then it ends with a narration from
the guy on the right
i missed him every day after that this
is ukraine rent
2021 [ __ ] yes but he also does that
weird thing the guy on the left does
that weird thing that they all do where
it's like
stare intensely and psychotically
directly into people's eyes
never break eye contact it's it i don't
know why they the pickup artists tell
you that's good and i know why they tell
you that
because the artists that they're trying
to help
they make literally no eye contact which
is not good
of course you have to make like you
shouldn't be putting any amount of
thought into the amount of eye contact
you're giving
because once you do you're [ __ ]
yourself like it shouldn't be too much
it shouldn't be enough you should
occasionally glance in somebody's eyes
as you're talking to them
so that they know hey we're still here
i'm still on the line
we're talking but when you're just like
you know i was just wondering what is it
that you do
for a living
me is it good work do you enjoy it
i have a boyfriend look at me
it's just like why i can't help but look
at you why would you do
like like eye contact is just yeah man i
was saying that last week to bubba
you look up occasionally in somebody's
eyes and you do these guys just go look
in the eyes and then the autistic ones
go
and it's like are you trying to shoot
lasers at me
somebody pointed something out in the
chat the guy on the left looks like
vsauce
it does yeah i definitely saw a lot like
michael from vsauce yeah ah right i
think i think we covered this enough for
today what he also looks a bit michael
stypish
okay let me see that which is probably
what he does when he's off camera that's
how he gets laid is he just goes around
and goes like um
rem remember doesn't it feel like
they're like six o'clock tv hour i don't
remember the words
and then the girl's like i'm sorry are
you a time traveler this is a 1999 i
i really don't care if you're from in
rem okay fine i'm moby
can we please go back to my hotel now
[Laughter]
who's moby exactly
i don't know ask the 1990s who's moby
the guy fat boy slim could have been um
i saw him on community right i know
that's the dean
the guy that was better than fat boy
slim but not good not as good as the
chemical brothers
correct somewhere right in the middle
there you go fat boy slim is pretty good
i can't [ __ ] on fat boy slim moby's
pissed he didn't get the matrix cake